[Musica]
il tema di questa edizione fearless è
molto importante soprattutto perché
connesso all universo femminile nel
corso di questo strano 2020 abbiamo
avuto paura di tante cose abbiamo avuto
paura di stare insieme di incontrarci di
nuocere alle persone che amiamo di non
saper rispondere alle sfide che ci
imponendo il domani e abbiamo avuto
paura anche di fare di non poter
mantenere il nostro stile di vita di
fare le piccole cose che ci piacciono
come andare alle vostre al cinema teatro
ai musei
insomma tutte le cose che hanno a che
vedere con il mondo della cultura nel
mio lavoro di giornalista di critico
d'arte di comunicatore registro ogni
giorno queste ansie anche tra gli
addetti ai lavori da chi opera nel
settore dell'arte della cultura al quale
io appartengo
io lavoro nel mondo dell'arte dal 2005
quindi da 15 anni
però appunto un mio amore per l'arte
contemporanea soprattutto è antecedente
e nasce quando le 12 anni
e sfogliando le pagine del sussidiario
di intere mentare mettere un sussidiario
veramente all'avanguardia trovo le
immagini delle opere di lucio fontana e
alberto burri sono proprio i sacchi di
burri quelli a essere per me una vera e
propria rivelazione rimango sconvolta e
decido che voglio saperne di più
[Musica]
soprattutto decido che avrei voluto
intraprendere studi d'arte
non ho mai pensato di fare l'artista non
vi ho mai avuto il talento ho sempre
saputo che volevo scrivere d'arte che la
parola sarebbe stata il mio mestiere e
dello sterminio
nel mio mestiere anche tutt ora però ho
scelto di fare un percorso di studi
abbastanza con anticonvenzionale perché
non ho scelto una carriera iniziale di
studi umanistici ma di iscrivervi prima
liceo artistico e poi all'accademia di
belle arti perché ho sempre pensato che
per scrivere d'arte bisognava vedere le
cose da dentro imparare i processi che
sottendono la creazione di un'opera e
soprattutto essere una compagna di
strada per per gli artisti e poi ho
fatto un corso di comunicazione delle
arti visive ho studiato per una laurea
storia dell'arte all'università però
sono convinta che quella prima fase
della mia formazione sia stata
estremamente importante lo sia ancora
oggi come dicevo io ho mosso i primi
passi in questo settore nel 2005 nel
corso di questi 15 anni il mondo del
lavoro è molto cambiato però non era
facile neanche all'inizio e anche allora
c'erano infatti in luce tutte le
problematiche che attraversano oggi il
mondo del lavoro precariato il classismo
gli stipendi bassi la difficoltà di
stipulare dei contratti di lavoro
corretti in più però c'è una minore
consapevolezza e la presenza veramente
ingombrante di una generazione
precedente che aveva fatto cose
importantissime ma che volente o nolente
me ma anche creato un blocco era
qualcosa con cui confrontarsi e
confrontarsi veramente tutti i giorni
nel 2006 ho cominciato a lavorare per
una società di bologna
a un progetto un festival di arte
contemporanea
un'esperienza bellissima che mi ha dato
molto mi ha arricchito grazie alla quale
ho conosciuto
praticamente i protagonisti dell'intero
settore dell'arte a livello
internazionale ascoltato le loro idee e
le loro opinioni
sull'uscita da con l'esperienza qui sono
veramente molto grata con non uno ma ben
più mestieri in tasca da lì è cominciato
tutto
sì ma non ho potuto fare a meno di
notare non solo nel mio progetto ma
anche in altri progetti in cui sono
incazzata come uditore o come semplice
passante come semplice spettatore che la
maggior parte dell'organizzazione dietro
le quinte quindi appunto capo la lamera
organizzazione la comunicazione di
allestimenti eccetera erano gestiti
quasi sempre da giovani domine e mi
ricordo molto bene che a un festival non
quello in cui lavoravo io un altro
progetto ho sentito una giovane collega
dire se spegnessimo loro i microfoni se
la smettessimo di far partire loro le
slide di tradurre dall'inglese
all'italiano che cosa succederebbe
secondo me ci sarebbe l'apocalisse e lei
si riferiva ai maschi un paese che
stavano sul palco ad ogni modo quella
frase mi è rimasta in mente come vi
dicevo nel corso di questi 15 anni molte
cose sono cambiate e le donne sono
maggiormente riconosciute alcuni di loro
occupano posti di potere c'è maggior
rispetto per le donne e le stesse donne
sono molto più brave a pretendere
rispetto per il loro lavoro ma c'è
ancora tanto da fare e in un articolo
che ho scritto recentemente per il
giornale in cui lavoro
un titolo inequivocabile come campano
le artiste le artiste lamentavano ancora
uno scarsissimo riconoscimento del patto
lavoro rispetto ai colleghi uomini è
abbastanza vero che il mondo dell'arte
ma anche quello della cultura in
generale della politica e la società
stessa
vivono in uno stato di fascinazione
collettiva per il secolo scorso e per la
produzione culturale conseguita
ma se è vero che in quei decenni
comunque molto ricchi vivissimi pieni di
idee sicuramente eroici si sono
costituiti e si sono costruiti
presupposti per il contesto peraltro
ancora non risolto in cui viviamo oggi
e se è vero che comunque la situazione
in corso non sarebbe possibile senza
tutti i movimenti che le donne hanno
portato avanti in quel periodo le donne
delle generazioni precedenti e anche
vero però che questo passato tanto
vagheggiato segue il filo conduttore di
un egemonia di sguardo maschile le
immagini della donna stessa della
famiglia che ci sono state tramandate
sono spesso filtrate dall'occhio e
maschile allora io mi chiedo se questo
presente
tanto vagheggiato se questo presente
chiedo scusa tanto bistrattato come
quello in cui viviamo oggi offrire
l'opportunità di uno spostamento
dell'asse in direzione di una visione
dell'arte femminile è una domanda che ci
dobbiamo porre sono ancora penso ancora
per poco troppo giovane per costruire
un'etica della mia vita e ne voglio
farlo e la mia strada professionale è
stata come per tutti costellata di
successi e di fallimenti ciò però di cui
sono fiera che è cercato fin dall'inizio
di sfuggire e che io non ho voluto
seguire quella che era indicata come la
strada giusta per fare le cose ho
cercato di inventarmi invece delle cose
di costruire un mio modello di appunto
lavorare a modo mio e negli hanno
incontrato tanti miei coetanei che la
pensavano come me la tendenza degli
ultimi anni alla professionalizzazione
del settore della cultura ha sicuramente
prodotto persone più consapevoli più
competenti ma allo stesso tempo anche
qualche fraintendimento non esistono né
ricette le formule soprattutto in un
settore come quello della cultura che
guarda l'inedito a lavorare nell'arte un
mestiere ma è anche una malattia assorbe
tutte le nostre vite
i nostri amori le nostre amicizie con si
smette mark non si stacca mai ciò
pertanto che vorrei consigliare ai
giovani e alle giovani donne che
intraprendono questa folle strada questa
strana partita di vita e di chiedere per
se stessi la credibilità che meritano e
di lavorare per costruire un
autorevolezza ai miei coetanei invece di
non fare l'errore di sottovalutarli ma
anzi di guidarli e di accompagnarli e
ancora tornando ai giovani di ascoltare
i consigli quelli buoni quelli cattivi
ma di sfuggire i diktat e i dog ma
bisogna fare le cose a proprio modo
e non bisogna avere paura
la musica i libri le opere ci saranno
sempre
e saremmo e saranno sempre una necessità
per tutti per noi per l'essere umano
qualunque cosa succede l'arte non muore
mai
grazie